it's a [ __ ] rock Monday everybody and
I'm gonna say this right out in front
we're gonna move on from this I just
want to say that John Jones lost that
fight now he did you would agree yeah
yes I got three two three two two one
the last two rounds that's right yeah
you got John first round I mean got
breas first round second round the round
I can see it a little dicey oh really
okay see the rounds though like not
clear from here okay that's well that's
where controversy comes well then you
know what you gotta take for Li you
gotta take the bottle with from the
champ that he dumped you don't want any
other state you and he'd walk away the
winner well can I see this when one of
judge does judges the first round don't
they give that card to somebody so they
don't they can't I think they they once
they judge the first round they go
that's around and they give it to
someone else who's neutral I think
unless they unless they tell you at all
at the end tell you know did they do
yeah that's not how boxing works because
boxing they'll judge the first round
boom they come there well and you see on
the bottom the card the word that's in
like the numbers are typed in then the
rest is written in right by the way
Tommy Gray has fought a great fight
moving laterally kept moving never let
John get off he looked great and he's a
better boxer probably and hits harder
yes I don't know can say anything that
John's the most successful light
heavyweight to ever do it so yeah he's a
better box I'll tell you this I think I
think you're a better thing raises every
bit the athlete John is probably would
you better athlete you know he's a
better athlete not a better fighter Oh
better say better athlete okay so he's a
serious athlete yeah as you could say
here's one double-a ball you know he
likes done yeah team captains Wow
football football big dink I didn't
write it any like NFL camp or anything
but they start training fighting well
there you go and and southpaw belief he
knew both yeah you stud started and
hasn't been fighting that long ago right
that's just 13th fight not a lot Wow no
yeah I think they fight again John's got
some problems and I'll tell you
something else
no I'll tell you something else I think
if John tries to fight Steve a message I
think he gets knocked out and all due
respect you off the junk I know this is
Emma Mayen Jen all the trainer no I'll
do my mouth dude no I'm not a full time
all due respect the job Jones who I love
although I say this with respect if he
fights sebum usage he gets knocked out
and I'll break it down for you steep em
usage is going to if if John if John if
Steve a gets John against the case the
way he raised gets the Giants case
steeper hits so hard and I think he's
gonna connect the knock him out if it
gets to a boxing match which it will
because I don't think John can wrestle
with he can wrestle with steep a but
he's gonna have just as much trouble or
more trouble with steep a because he's a
better wrestler than rares so then the
wrestling gets neutralized mmm you got
that front kick you got that step that
that thigh stomp
I think steep a closes distance on that
and then now it's a boxing match and he
gets in a boxing match steep a winter
and that you should bring this to
Stallone's house and they're gonna love
it you don't agree with that do it you
don't agree with that here arm when you
do it here yeah so we say wrestling's
neutralized yes go off let's just start
with your first greatman neutralize yeah
would you say DC's a better wrestler
there CP yes I would okay John took him
down I understand so that doesn't the
neutralize that would have didn't take
down Reyes great takedown defense hold
on hold on let's just go off that okay
took him down didn't control him stood
up Kerr also took him down in the the
fourth and fifth because he's losing the
fight that's how you know Dom was win
the fight yeah because once I saw him
saw John Shu right he knew his rights in
the fight that's why I shot correct he
could have took him down and whenever he
wanted but he realized he was losing
down on the scorecard so he started
taking Ryland doesn't take steeper down
anytime he wants
well again took DC down to Dustin down
yeah to again much more a credible
credible wrestlers not as big I think
that plays a factor I think state pays
big I think he's excellent wrestler so I
think what happens is if they get into
clinch
if they get in the clinch game I I'm
favoring steep a if they get into a
takedown thing it's gonna be tough to
take stipa down I don't think here's
what I mean I don't think Jon's
takedowns are ours to a threat anymore a
threat to see pay then to anybody else
or less so so I don't think steepy asked
a game plan for that takedown I'm saying
no okay so you know John has the most
takedowns ever in light heavyweight
history
light heavyweight not heavyweight
big difference and so you know DC beat
steeping John beat him twice yeah yeah
and Steve babe knocked wait I'm sorry
it's deep a knock DC out yes
DC not sleepy out I'll reverse that DC
knocks TP out then Steve a knock these
correct John beat DC twice right
once my head kicking yeah oh yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be interesting I'm
stammers I'm do you represent the MMA
community no guy has a little bit of
trouble and was like he's beat a wall
he's hurt wow it's boys beautiful for a
guy like Steve man I think if they get
into I think it's gonna come down to a
fisticuffs and if it does I believe
steep a knock johnner love and that's
and that's not saying I'm not being
disrespectful
I'm just saying that I I think that's a
steep a is he knocks so many people out
he's got that he's just so [ __ ]
powerful I think he probably hits harder
than Reyes I think that's fair to say
just buy it
heavyweight yeah and I think that you
know you can't I I believe also though
John may adjust I think John's highly
intelligent and he'll be he'll adjust
and not maybe fight the same way he
fought against Reyes game plan but you
know John's never lost a rematch ever
destroyed finishes the guy who done the
day being did that with Gustafson will
say NDC Astra hmm it's like I'm talking
to MMA form right now no everyone's like
I'm out he's older I didn't say the [ __ ]
he beat such as they bit well well I
guess we'll take it we'll have a
gentlemen's bet on that because I'm
saying so gentlemen's bet I'll bet you
five grand okay and I don't want to go
crazy cuz it's MMA and you're not gonna
pay no no but but I of steep it will
knock him out that's not saying I think
the thinking they're gonna get into a
boxing match and I think I don't think
anybody can handle steep ace power and I
think it's gonna get into that I think
it's gonna get into a boxing match cool
man yeah and you disagree with that I'm
just not on the train of Oh John you
know John's he'll lose his next fight or
any of that I I think I think Steve I
think it's fighting the best heavyweight
of all time in some ways a heavyweight
that's I'm not saying he's gonna lose
his next fight he's fighting steep a
music no I know I know
do you know what's going on with Steve
in our design and
and all that I don't I haven't fought in
a while so when you go when you go off
like someone who's like as far as like
aging steep a would be the the more long
and the tooth as far as how old a steep
a check you know he's a firefighter yeah
he's got some wars that was that died he
why I didn't like the way he was talking
after the 37 huh that's out there
how old is John 32 I believe 30 to 33
I'm using you but the thing is there's
not to worry about the a drop see he's
definitely younger but just as far as
damage taken yeah it's a lot of damage
right there's a lot of damage there so I
lords with his wars with JDS like those
were yeah man yeah Overeem fight was
tough like there was he's had some wars
wars again you there's only me is the
greatest every weight of all yeah that's
all I'm saying and I think that and I
think he's boxing is you know what it
looked like to me honestly it looked
like John wasn't willing to I was like
why isn't he jabbing why isn't he
throwing shots
I might might I think what happened was
they were like look rays knocks
everybody out don't get into a boxing
match with him kick kick him keep him at
a distance pick your shots which made
sense right so because they were in
boxing distance I was like why is y'all
not getting in these but then I saw
Reyes dipping and throwing up counter
fights up yeah yeah yeah and I was like
Jesus okay that makes sense because I
couldn't figure it out and then I was
like well he's gonna you don't wanna get
into a brawl with that guy because he's
really powerful so that's that's what
I'm saying and I don't know I don't know
how if they I don't know how they how
they avoid getting into boxing distance
and now now I favor steep a is that fair
I mean I guess I John's the greatest of
all time in boxing distance maybe Gusman
who have seen annihilate heavy
world-class heavyweight boxers and
acting he's the you know he's making
John Jones it's amazing after one fight
you're acting like I'm dissing John I'm
not no I'm acting like you you I don't I
don't know maybe it's cuz you because
you start drawing it out class and box
I didn't think got out of class at all
because I blanked I think that I think
that his camp probably said don't box
with him kick out his SS now I think Dom
was moving so much yeah he was he's
moving non-stop so yes just you keep
saying the smartest smart way it was
like yeah very smart way to fight him
just kept moving back and forth and all
that I was [ __ ] smart yeah the Dom
like phenomenal man yeah phenomenal he
did we'll see hopefully that's the fight
do you know I can get the rematch UFC
doesn't do rematch is really you're not
getting rematch I don't think so but and
I don't think he goes well for Dom when
they rematch it's just cuz trying to
which the way you were gonna beat him
that was your one time to do it and then
it's like it's over man well that that
makes sense because John was clip was
winning it four and five I think
oh yeah well he had won things yeah no
one gave Dom yeah and if three was up in
the air then then it was a good decision
well yeah you've got a champ I gaze a
champion sees I don't mmm I don't do
that a five-round fight a five-round
fight whether it's on the prelims or
what it doesn't matter yeah it's a fight
Dom won three other first time I've ever
seen John John's lose manures it's the
first time so Reyes didn't that Gustin
fight was almost that was close a Santos
fight was a split decision yeah he's
fighting dogs dogs dogs now I would
argue that John didn't take this fight
serious oh I'm not taking anything Dom
did but I would argue that John was out
at the Super Bowl festivities the week
before now what he did I don't know but
if I have the biggest fight of my life
coming up which every title fight for
him is a beast lady's life I'm probably
not to me in Miami at Super Bowl
it's are taken in festivities very
interesting very interesting I I do I
think it's hard for John to get up for
these fights I really do
really mm-hmm sacré do not big names
he's just like I'm so much better these
guys yeah whatever I think he's getting
older and these guys are young and
talented Dom so talented so even though
you know the pub hasn't afford one dog
but Dom has all the skills yeah if John
hangs around long enough that it's gonna
catch up with him I'm sorry
of course three summers of cockfights in
any other state John loses and that's
judges friends that's on that might like
my thing is if you give them steep a in
the world heavyweight title is on the
line training do you think John's gonna
get up for that fight yeah I do I'm very
excited about that fight I hope they do
it I don't know you don't think that you
think there's a chance they won't I
don't know who knows what the UFC's
gonna do this it's really what John he's
defended his 205 title like Rogan said
he's more than anybody else will hold up
defended the title more than anybody
Baker on it's in front of 14 times
that's incredible
so he's the greatest fighter to ever
step into the Octagon yep without
question
so if he beats steep eh I'll build a
[ __ ] shrine to him yeah hopefully
they do it hopefully steep a wants it
like it to be fun man I hope it happens
yeah I'm not too interested in the
rematch I don't know I I so Steve Bates
got an eye issue
he took up beating with that something
going on with his body
it's right charli's I was cleared though
and then he still didn't want to come
back he's saying he wants to heal it
more and that's why Daniel Cormier was
like come on what are you doing like we
should get this fight back so much Jesus
my issues nothing joke around is it's
not good again he's got some wars dude
great fight though great fight loved it
excited I'm saying it's deep a job a
great fight mm-hmm a great fight big
news everybody
yep it's finally happening this is the
year I'm gonna straight my bottom teeth
with candid clear aligners it's all set
in motion I'm gonna straighten these bad
boys up if you're anything like me and
you're not crazy about when you smile
all right you're not crazy about little
self-conscious and the photos and
selfies I recommend you check out candid
they deliver clear aligners directly to
you straighten your teeth for 65% less
than braces also who's wearing braces
unlike braces candy clear aligners are
comfortable removable and totally
invisible plus you never have to set
foot in a doctor's office or waiting
room your treatment is prescribed
remotely by a licensed orthodontist and
then it shipped right to your door
or look ahead maybe you got a wedding
big special event coming up maybe got a
family reunion high school reunion and
you want your grill on point cool it
takes just around six months the average
time about six months you know start
seeing results way before then to get
your teeth straight on up so are you
ready to take the first step toward
straighter teeth for a limited time you
can get started with $75 off by using
the code fighter at candy-coat comm
slash fighter
that's candid koat.com slash fighter use
code fighter for $75 off can decode comm
slash fighter you know sometimes you pee
on deodorant fellows you don't know if
it's safe or not someone has aluminum in
it but I'm here to save you I want you
guys to live longer and smell nice I'm
talking about- it's safe native Jonah is
formulated without aluminum its
ingredients you know you've heard of
coconut oil you've heard of shea butter
we got you and it works
switching to aluminum Friederich does
not mean you have to sacrifice um
performance you me smelling fresh all
damn day and they have amazing sense my
favorites the coconut vanilla it's most
popular mint and eucalyptus say what
something for everyone men women teens
we got you unscented so to free formula
for those with sensitive skins no risk
to try free shipping on every order in
native offers 30-day free returns and
exchanges in the US of A and they're
also launching their toothpaste again
the most natural toothpaste
alright you teeth be clean you smell
nice they got your too minty flavors
they got whitening wild mint and
peppermint oil we gotcha
alright these two face can do it all
whitens freshens and prevents cavities
[Music]
you guys get a special code right now
native deodorant comm use promo code TFA
TK alright 25 native deodorant calm
promo code t f8 ek that's the fighter in
the kitten promo code t f8 ek native
deodorant calm Twitter sent off your
entire order I'm excited I hope they do
it I hope they do I know
where'd you watching it Luke Rockhold
house here and I was tyke him trying to
get Luke to like break down the fight
for me as I was watching it no one wants
to do that dude yeah he's like man he
think I'm watching and he's like conceal
it is he in LA now yeah he's the great
device got a great place where and now
I'm like you know around oh yeah yeah
yeah and he's if he's done done right I
hope so I think he's grappling a little
bit I was just doing some grappling
Mia's yeah but he's got a lot of other
[ __ ] going on yeah you know sure yeah
the best great what what did you do how
was uh where were you Santonio how was
San Antonio started yeah favorite hotel
in the world dude uh-huh little ones
that time you did I am NOT San Antonio
in a long time they wanted me I didn't
outlet they wanted me to do August and
I've done it before I simply can't do I
can't do yeah I can't do it and I was
attacked by Locust last time while I was
on stage and I was attacked by locusts
last time I was attacked by a biblical
cloud of locusts and I'm not gonna have
how they get in there well I don't know
but apparently I'm a sinner and they
came at me and I got hit in the [ __ ]
cheek and a woman screamed because one
man I'm not hurt and then one landing on
me then I look at hovered and [ __ ]
locusts I was like hey can we not let
locusts in here is it gonna start
raining frogs next the [ __ ] is going on
here
hello weirdos game from can't have it it
was one day it was super hot and Jake
kept wanna go down the river walk okay
we're on a grown-man tonic walking down
the river unless you grow a set of tits
I'm not walking down here with that dude
people are not we did any meals down
there either no it's him you get some
people that have eaten they keep eating
a lot I'm assuming I'm with so few of
these thick boy sweatshirt source
Antonia I like that yeah did you make
those yeah I think I'm going to send be
sent a few of these this tax general oh
yeah yeah everything's big and I didn't
give me the thousand pound sister's
hands mm-hmm yeah I like those thick boy
yeah yeah there's some thick he's down
there doesn't think he's yeah listen
thank you see again yeah there's some
eatin that goes on great food great food
Oh Stevie Bluett came down oh yeah I saw
I Six Flags I get video got sick you did
well just save
we're older when the roller-coaster went
on one and then Mach I could say [ __ ]
with like my equilibrium line it was
dizzy for the rest of the day what
happens I did shoe and I like we're out
of here well my son I went on the thing
that goes up and down I I was like I'm
gonna throw up right now this is gonna
be a disaster of them Thea
oh oh my girl took Tiger to Universal we
took him on he was bright like - he
can't go on anything so he didn't have
fun but she took him when I was gone
yeah and she took him on the jet she's
on a jurassic bike ride you know there's
that big t-rex and there's that huge
jump you should see his face he's it's
the most he's so terrified oh yeah your
terror [ __ ] day I was laughing so she
sent to me she was laughing so hard I've
never seen a kid scared I don't know if
Johanna posted or not chill okay never
seen a kid scared
that's so primordial did you watch the
Oscars I did what do you think didn't
watch him don't watch any party I'm not
invited to but I'm glad parasite won but
I also was hoping Joker we win of course
not because I'm in it but because I
think it's well Joker Joker won best
actor of course yeah I mean parasite one
I haven't seen peer so I can't really
great movie no great movie hey dude I
sorry I know how that was so crazy
random I don't think there's anyone it
was pure sight is yeah I'm have to watch
my favorite movie that that and joke are
my two favorite movies though I I didn't
watch it okay but after you Joker's
fantastic Oh so joke is so good
I got Joker actually is ultimately
better but parasitize I'm glad this
Korean movie won he must be a national
hero oh my god cuz you're representing
Korea I mean [ __ ] it Hollywood yeah yeah
Korea came over to Holly we took oh
that's so great my boy Brad Pitt won
yeah everything about time right did a
great job he did a great job in the
pauses like that acting of doing of
doing nothing was amazing like he just I
don't know that the pauses he won for he
won for what he didn't say and how he
was so good yep he told Leonardi goes
I'll ride your coattails anytime man I
said I say yeah wow it was so good Wow
amazing man that's what Netflix loses
out on pretty much everything damn you
didn't saw the picture but what picture
on I couldn't find that you can see
Laura Dern and that I love Renee
Zellweger my girl one fer
she just wins Oscars whenever she
decides to act Renee took what ten years
off and was like I'm gonna come back and
do this now I just saw the beginning of
Judy she's great in that
yeah it looks different my friend said
she's gonna win I was like Jimmy Broncos
just give it to her now damn it's such a
big deal god damn what a comeback for
Renee I have no desire through that
marriage story just two people arguing
[ __ ] yeah Adam driver
yeah he's phenom I heard it's really
good I saw Adam driver on stage nominal
who won Best Director oh yeah I'm sorry
boy yeah and that won best film too yep
that's why it so it was shot like it was
shot that's why I wouldn't cry want you
to watch it running because when you
look at it the way looks on Phil I know
I wanna hug it man I should wait - Kim's
the [ __ ] children you've seen Jojo
rabbit no I want to see her tits so good
Jay love Jojo rabbit Wow nine nineteen
seventeen one for what I've seen a lot
of these movies cinematography oh yeah I
heard that's amazing - American Factory
Oh best documentary I got to see that
all the documentaries man another
documentary i watch her up there there's
a new documentary for Malcolm X on that
flicks oh really yeah it's like that can
especially behind his murder I love this
guy who's just balls deep in the murder
of Malcolm X I watched part one last
night it's so interesting
really oh it's so interesting so it's
crazy you just doing that speech in New
York dude yeah and then to get away the
only reason they caught one is because
the personal security for Malcolm X shut
they're doing the leg and then the crowd
got him they're gonna kill him the cop
saved him took him to prison to him jail
how do they think it was well again I'm
only on Episode one from what I always
say right you know cuz Malcolm X was
part of the Islam nation and he won
against many pro quo the yeah the
Prophet Muhammad he went against gosh
Elijah Muhammad you want to get like
just was like I'm out and so they said
cuz three bikers that shot him as far as
they know they said it was you know the
Mohammed all the path yeah they said it
was his doing because you know his gifts
Malcolm X but they said the CIA and the
FBI everybody knew that they were gonna
do that probably but they were like go
ahead done yeah like we're not gonna
interfere with it like you're doing us a
favor create like division yeah they
were just like if you were no there
weren't a lot of black guys in the FBI
it wasn't CIA's FBI cuz he I remember
there's a firewall so the FBI yeah it's
not allowed to involved be involved in
domestic issues see the FBI especially
back but FBI especially they were
sitting there like yeah you're doing us
a favor
like well obviously we see what years
are gonna do yeah do you think so there
was no cops present and I was like to
when usually there'd be a whole squad
they were like Jeffrey and do it do it
man that that that I believe and then
the murder scene they said they just
walked in was just like yeah I mean yeah
would you have ax amor their base like
what do you think was gonna happen
yeah but you want to talk about all this
violence when she seems to happen so it
was like and and then here's what's
crazy he is shot right in New York that
night that place was rented out for a
dance where the crime scene happened
they still had to dance that Wyatt so
all the evidence in what they had a
[ __ ] ballroom dance no and so that
it's like marked off but it's like dude
who of course people were [ __ ] with
the crime scene guy and they they show
like the legit pictures of him being
shot [ __ ] I've read two of his books am
I read by any means necessary and I read
I read a bunch of his speeches I think
there was that there's another book but
he was great yeah he said I will not
live long enough to read my own
biography yeah he told his wife he had
several conversations other were like
you know he's smart dude he's like it's
a matter of time before somebody shoots
me and he kept he kept preaching her
like it's just a matter of time it's
gonna happen we have to accept it and
they were like you know there were
several several attempts to kill him
before yeah what a badass and then
before this happened his his daughter
and kids were in the house and people
through you know those cocktail bomb
yeah house try to out the house right
and then the but guess what happen
so they get the cops out there like now
he did that just to give attention
I would [ __ ] would I blow up my own
house I'm have insurance they burn all
my furniture what are you talking about
so his wife when she's on camera after
her husband died she goes and let me
guess she was gonna say he shot him he
did this himself that was help I gotta
see this dogs it's fascinating
I gotta see this you forget what times
were like back on manners [ __ ] well
crazy
you couldn't vote crazy you were black
you couldn't vote in a lot of states
yeah have you seen Denzel Washington
portrayal of oh it's I watched it
watching school I'm you were in a school
you watch those movies they'd be so
boring like I'll [ __ ] I remember Michael
I'm right max it was so good but we had
to watch it in like a week right you
have to watch it Monday Tuesday Thursday
I couldn't wait to get to that class and
finish the movie he did a great job he'd
know he's so good in that oh yeah he's
so good I loved him in that I mean I was
a very good movie power was that Spike
Lee who did that likely Spike Lee's in
it too yeah he was so [ __ ] good yes
good looks a lot like a man they does
mmm phenomenal movie yeah that
documented he renounced violence here
announced the violent overthrow this
thing was it by any means necessary
you want you want you want to treat us
like [ __ ] we can treat you like after
day by for a night I have a right to
protect my for a night yeah I'm not good
with cold cuts he dude right walls you
[ __ ]
I know man the cojones on that man it's
crazy but knew he was in the right we
lost all our white nationalist person I
apologize you see what happens say some
racist we'll get him back exactly well
the blacks lost our Nazi and white
nationalist listeners I'm sorry guys
what else you got your though you got
your adorable sneakers on these are
these old things the wag the dogs yeah
some do you brought me custom sneakers
in San Antonio really yeah you don't say
yeah little your people bring a lot of
whiskey drinking a lot of whiskey dude
you haven't you have a little problem
ah no it's hip I'm dialing back a little
bit but now I'm bringing okay there I am
okay now
bringing bottles to the bedroom now
there you are is that your hotel
yeah and they gave you a leather couch
like that
well Papa that's my place yeah the top
of the suite you really like that right
that hotel what does it like it looks
like it's a Dotel Emma it looks like
it's a modern wood I mean it not Aman oh
it wasn't a retro who used to be a
brewery but that's that's a library Oh
whiskey oh dude you would die it's our
style oh my god it's like Abbott Kenny
it all in one hotel okay you don't want
to leave the premises the food
everything
Wow look at that here for Papa when he
rocked it really a no you know it's a
people bring me their own whiskeys
because they might have their own
distillery so then I'm trying whiskeys
now my kidneys hurt yeah how are your
kids they're all right no I mean the
kidneys my kidneys the better yeah three
Emmys fun drink some water more fluids I
take these cranberry pills supposed to
be helping do you have any idea what it
could be beside something very serious I
like that you're not a hypochondriac
now you have some major issues in your
hand that power through it yeah power
through it it was nice though what are
those they're they got you some peanuts
no [ __ ] J was the immuno J a penis on
his [ __ ] teeth J gets her on Thursday
by the oh he does yeah I'm gonna be a
pop icon in life I got a West Palm Beach
come see me at the improv this weekend
Friday Saturday Sunday you're doing a
Sunday I'm doing a so I'm gonna get back
in Monday I'll get back at 10:00 I'll be
ready okay yeah don't worry I'm taking a
5:30 a.m. flight so I can be back for
the pod yeah feel sick
got [ __ ] rock on Monday and I don't like
missing Monday's I keep us in the TOC
Rock yeah it kind of kills me can we say
also real quick just so people know that
we're on a different camera just for
today because I was a random egg so that
we got a fixed camera because I'm I was
on set and I had a a window and I we
were playing on not shooting yeah but I
had to do it
can't it had to come a-runnin dude how
much fun did we have shooting that
commercial oh is that what it reminded
me of what we do it for and we were just
silly [ __ ] geese we were doing that
commercials for pure spectrum see the
oil and so outrageous it was soon as
last there's the picture look at you and
your dumb mustache that's a giant muff
that's the whole point of everything it
was so [ __ ] funny it's a whole point
of everything so as obviously Brian be
D'Elia
Fahim Santino Michael
poor dear Kisan I think what we do is we
start doing commercials for companies
with that with that group pass with
these wait to see these commercials any
any [ __ ] company that wants
commercials let's have a talk and we'll
do some great [ __ ] take a look at the
pure spectrum when it comes out yeah and
let me talk about you see these
commercials yeah right the rap is so
funny
really yeah itself look how thick is
that mustache is yeah yep that was fun
though we had ourselves a suicide would
ya thick cowboy the thicky cowboy you're
the thicky cowboy pick him up and pose
down got a little wrestling tussle this
weekend with a guy who's fairly large
but compared to you everybody feels
manageable who is this compared to you
everybody feels well I need you don't
know Susie what's he do
I just was a jujitsu guy no he's easy
easy easy
he's my comic comic but but he's a
complex ballplayer
six five Tom yeah yeah Kevin Mack great
guy and kmac is is a is a an athlete
everything he [ __ ] I would not want to
tussle um he's much bigger than I am a
speech that let a guy but I'm saying
that we were joking around and just to
feel a guy like that is is the
difference between you and everybody
else is at least I'm not with a polar
bear they sent out with a [ __ ] polar
bear came back and you guys start
wrestling you grab man where'd you guys
wrestle at Luke's Luke tried to jump in
and I [ __ ] kicked his leg out you
defended wrestled I def backflip yours
were just wrestling around just a couple
guys doing some light wrestling doing
some light lubed up and did some light
wrestling Rathlin you guys want a
wrestle hey guys what do you you want to
do want to do some wrestling well I was
full of opinions you should have seen me
at Luke's guys next to me asked me
questions about the John Jones fight and
I'm going like this watch test probably
do what you did just start he's dipping
he might get kicked I don't want a dip
it's not that he's getting he's figuring
out his patterns makes Papa sick yeah
but I know my shed dude you know what
the best everyone knows me so when we
watch the fights in the green room
everybody's cool
I made sure then I'm gonna just watch
this now see how his win in that corner
there guys hey put on the
outside I go look you wanna have your
foot on that look goes like this I mean
not always once again not always hoof
dicey yeah I say local why is he not
throwing punches Lucas it's a fight you
don't know what's going on maybe you
hurt his hand like this classic fight
one stuff he's like you don't know he's
just maybe you hurt his hand there's a
thousand things that's why they unless
you've been in there you don't know
everything in life I love everything in
life forget fighting is details if you
haven't done it you're not gonna
understand the details you know I
understand the nuances the little as you
get older you start to realize things
are way more complicated when it gets
into it in fact as you get older um
whatever it is that the person is doing
where I knew some great actors in acting
class
I mean actors that would [ __ ] floor
you they could do [ __ ] and you'd be like
well he's the best actor of all time
they couldn't put it together in the
audition room because just gonna notice
things yes they ran their own wedding
reasons and it's like my accent he's not
a magnet it's a nice taste one I said
this guy was such a stud really
good-looking and he did a scene I never
forgot this he did a scene that was so
good that I was watching it and I was
like I don't know how to do that like I
don't know how he made those choices he
was that good the whole class is like
this right and the teacher goes let's
just say his name was [ __ ] Ken and he
goes Ken you know you remind me of
you're like this beautiful car this
beautiful fast race car I mean the kind
of car that makes you think about sex
and makes you think that everything is
possible the kind of car that most
people look at as you drive by it you
know that envy that happens in a man who
was a car guy and I'm a car guy because
you're just one of those cars
unfortunately I'm not allowed to drive
because it would rather just sit in the
garage and you know that that guy looked
out and I didn't see him again he knew
what was up yeah I didn't see him again
he never he never made it he never got
out of his own way dude there was I was
like when we're doing commercials so we
had like loose ideas what we're gonna do
and I told Brian Santino Fahim and
Scalia I'm like here's the idea you guys
make it your own
this is what I'm gonna do and then you
guys make it your own and I left there
just like I texted Elia that's unlike I
wish my brain worked like yours did cuz
we're meeting him we're in the back I go
here's what I'm thinking - Neos mm-hmm
here's what some other people do I go
only Brian's guide tell him yours he's
laughs and he's like he's so stupid I
thought about it and then he goes all
right all right yeah I think I'm ready
literally just like I think I'm ready
and then goes where's the camera you
know him where's the camera and does his
pitch yeah it's Chris D'Elia yeah he's a
beast one face in the world he's also an
amazing actor he's so Chris is actually
you should see dude the camera guys were
shaking laughing shaking really oh dude
I was and I'm so see miked up going back
and forth him and I'm like I'm laughing
so hard and then freaking uh for him and
Santino go together I'm just like oh
well I mean the vast man literally the
[ __ ] batter they're so funny yeah it
was so [ __ ] funny man just good
actors and ah stupid it's like would he
come up with that name one time got up
and he was like I want to do my kicks I
want to do high kicks see my kicks I
work on my kicks
that's [ __ ] high kicking super high
and just set the car so we're all
[ __ ] dying just the dumbest [ __ ] oh
he's so his sketches he's got a funny
face man [ __ ] hilarious he sews the
picture with hmm I look like they're
dead okay their stepdad that's a great
shot so I'm so glad they're rebooting
rebooting Saved by the Bell
Oh leave yourself you know yeah I was
laughing on the plane to San Antonio man
I couldn't stop [ __ ] laughing I'm so
funny could not stop laughing it was sad
say it's a boy let's keep Brennan as the
loudmouth Hispanic neighbor with crazy
ideas andrew is the alcoholic high
school friend who still regrets leaving
his fiancee for a stripper and Fahim is
the good-hearted guy who just can't say
no to either them three in the bush
coming to you Pia
he's born that's putting a party that's
good your boy Brady owner of pure
spectrum bought me ENL dinner he goes
where should I go to dinner I said I saw
Mary scopa oh I saw Mark Sanchez too I
run into Mark Sanchez in the scope Oh
yup is sitting next to Brady belt so I'm
like the mayor and mark marks awesome
and we're just it was great we're just
kind of hanging out and and then Brady
bought me dinner he brought your dad and
I said who are you I had no I was with
some friends and I go if I had known
would have ordered a much more expensive
the one time I didn't get the teeth off
this rock at one time I order you get
the state i got nothing i got i got some
apps I was feeling light I ate a little
bit and I order for the first time a $52
bottle of white wine I'm usually going
here I usually sit in the bill yeah
because I'm actually where's all this
fancy wine I don't get it and the one
time and I was like thanks thank could
of let's go he took care of it though
good man good dude
good man God I'm gonna scope in forever
dude it's will you yeah you don't live
close by anymore I know it's a bummer it
misses you dude Valentine's Day Friday
I'm gonna be in West Palm
where you gonna be Ontario do you leave
Friday relief Thursday well it's in
Terios yeah they're drive Sun now enjoy
that because judge amaze will be flying
to Florida because it takes that one can
take same time we'll see floors play six
hours yeah this is taking three hours
you get those three hours bags yeah
that's where my doing what size my self
driving test that's what you want to use
I should let you do that you just go I
think I can't wait last time I was in
Ontario you and I were out there very
last time yeah they've they've redone
the whole closet yeah all the way better
way better it was always good crowds
I don't yeah always [ __ ] around to is
that it's in the Inland Empire sir in
the Inland Empire right now it's an hour
and 30
uh-huh right now it's [ __ ] it's 1:30
yeah there's like no trouble Papa's
being that traffic get five mm-hmm oh
that's gonna be a good time on a Friday
that Bell good nice not to be flying in
your opera I'm sick of fly yeah I can
drive home at night stay in my bed wake
up with Tiger
it's so great you're the flying man huh
it's a [ __ ]
it's a tortoise it's a margin yeah man I
might my son had Cub Scouts on Sunday
and I was teaching my throat you still
do girls girls they do even like all
those like so like trying to yeah but
it's all pet dad's there it's like
trying to wrangle cats though the
football the kids just there they're
eight they don't get although don't talk
to them about like anything uh they just
like when they're fighting some of the
kids you know some kids have behavioral
problems so they freak out and we're
playing ultimate frisbee that nobody
knows what that is nobody has teams
nobody knows how to throw a frisbee one
kids tackling one kids just [ __ ]
tackling the other kids punching them I
like your style
yeah it's just a chaos of me to you my
kids doing with Venice Venice Beach
freaking soccer club and so you know
therefore it's like yeah you don't want
to get off the grass it's just it's
namin eleven players you'll get two
brothers that start ganging up any weird
it's chaos I just start laughing in such
cast my son's talking to a blade of
grass looking in the opposite direction
yeah I did funny I go Finn you got to go
out for a bass because I'm not a team
sports guy because he's Pryor yeah I'm
not a team sports guy dad then I'm like
them then we're gonna go to jujitsu and
we're just hanging out
and he goes dead I feel like today
because we are both father-son we should
just do a father-son thing and not go to
Gigi's he's not lying
what would you like to do this maybe we
just sit and watch TV together what do
you think and then we can eat some color
he wants to chill like you want to chill
I I had career day at school so I go to
class these are eight year olds and I'm
an actor well great is that
this is a second grade and so they're
all so sweet and I and I and I begin to
show them the difference between someone
who's a very bad man well am i speaking
says snarling that does that make you
all
does that make you scared I bet they
love they love everything I'm teaching
them how to play like I'm seasoned like
you compare a black girl like this or
they start a life and I go and then I
can go yeah they love it it why am i
smiling but you don't trust me and they
were like yeah
about the data us go after who's the
realtor oh well Doug that dude hi one
career day yeah
hi [ __ ] one career dead like reducer
the Andrew freed of last chance you
about created the whole thing he's so
fun I didn't know man he goes he goes
hey guys not to be a jerk but I want
career day and I'm like ah this guy's
awesome funny it was so funny but he did
last chance you Nielsen's here cheer
that's my [ __ ] yeah he's the guy I'm
gonna have tenor with him you should
come out he's [ __ ] great guy but it
was so fun because with the kids I said
alright we're gonna have an acting
lesson now I'm going to have the
porridge and you have to come up to me
and say please can I have some more I'm
very hungry
it's from Oliver Twist and they would do
it in it and while you're not holding
your ball hold your ball properly right
that's they so most of the kids because
they're children they're not they're
just like laughing and I go you're
laughing you're not hungry I believe you
and then this kid comes up and he goes
he's Leonardo DiCaprio walking a orzo
goes please
I'm hungry can I have some food I have
some more did was he trained the kids go
give him food give him food I go oh
right my son
and he goes back and he and he takes him
he keeps doing it would it be Jesse I'm
like this kids appease my son comes up
because please sir can I have some food
and I kind of believed him and I give
him the food and he goes hey roasted it
the kids I'm like dude you fed her okay
yeah it was great so then I do the same
thing with this dragon like okay you
guys gonna see a dragon you're reading
and you're just gonna hear a noise and
then you're gonna have to see the dragon
and you tell me what you do so all the
kids are like some kids that get up
they'd see the dragon because I they're
all clowns
this kid again nothing kid this same kid
reading a book white kids go yep long
hair beautiful boy a very dramatic space
he's reading the book I go oh and the
kid just goes I swear to god he does
this every kid goes uh whatever I make
the noise and he goes like this he goes
[Music]
like he's up there but dude he was so
terrified I was like and he didn't move
and I go oh this kids a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh no he said it some kids just have
have it he's just an Emmy Award is
amazing Oscar winner he's a [ __ ]
Oscar winner I was blown away I was like
and dramatic like the eyes big eyes you
know the the pants you tell him I don't
but I want to
you should find I mean it is and I hate
your kids yeah might be able to do
something here I don't want her I know
my mom's like chichi I don't want to
ruin that kid's life as a child actor it
doesn't work out it's never worked it's
not a good situation for a lot of child
actors although AJ masako's am I might
one of my co-star has been acting since
she was nine she's so good so she can
sing dance to everything yeah so it
depends there's some there's no Caprio
yes something he was one there's a few
but yeah yeah usually tough it's tough
the top man yeah but to see the
difference a table in talent it's like
sports yeah you can tell you can tell
this habit my daughter plays lacrosse
problem is she's 11 she's playing with
she's 6th grader she's playing with 8th
graders
that's eating that the night and a day
when they're girls there with with one
girl I believe was Samoan because she
was she squats way more than 8th grade
and I'm not in being here to go no no
sure she was a runner I thought about
you because I know you were an amazing
the crossfire love Lucas there's just
nothing my daughter could do and she
would just catch the ball just go they
scored that like she scored 12 goals I
was like she's got a pass hey come on
Moana breaking ball and then another
girl this girl with red hair same thing
just [ __ ] show yeah I'm both eighth
graders my she was learning in secret my
daughter because that's the age bracket
my daughter was like now I can't get out
of the way my daughter's tall and skinny
she's like she goes I try to put my my
stick and then you wouldn't you were
probably exact I can imagine exactly
that with you what you dominated your
Ivy League Player of the Year or I mean
I know not a freshman friend were you
all-american no mmm but
I like Ross is getting bigger out here
in California but for your daughter to
be playing with eighth-grade that's like
you know Missouri crying it's grown
women well the difference between I mean
just that a like even how that like my
son would be for next week from four to
five is huge it's large your vacation
yeah more to motor skills well the one
woman who gets me my coffee she said to
me in the morning she said she said
something about playing lacrosse all
four years and I go my daughter plays
lacrosse she goes tell you and this is
Oklahoma man she goes ah I got something
for your daughter she's playing with all
the girls tell her to do the sassy
braids or something I go what's the
sassy bread she goes take her braids
tied tight and put something or put
something hard on the end of it and then
when she gets close just whip that thing
around right in their face I was like oh
I'm not doing that I'm not telling my 11
year old to kung-fu a girl with her
braids like sassy break you [ __ ]
kidding me
whipper in the face the crowd oh Jesus
Christ the cross is a great game though
it seems I would wake up yeah yeah there
was a difference in the boys results
it's free steak with Nets if there's any
boys noises there's a different [ __ ]
yeah great game won't you play for God I
started freshman in high school and then
two years in college I loved it man you
are using such a good shade super easy
for you no not easy no lo it's it's a
rich kid sport man that's why the Ivy
League's are really good at it like the
private schools were really really good
and there is a professional league but
you could have been a professional if
you want I don't know there's a
professional league but again those guys
have been doing since they were kids
all right let's so what if your kids get
out lacrosse good way to get in those
great schools like Dukes phenomenal UNC
Harvard the D you'd ever Denver's teams
the best in the nation Stefan
northeastern North they I went just go
up there that's where it's been New York
and coast is baby don't you know Harvard
yeah lacrosse MIT
yep yeah it never really picked up here
though man it's never really like gain
traction for the reveal
soccer yes football soccer time what
happens to football and kids is that
changing already
no I think that I think the
participations down a little bit but hey
I don't think you're not there in the
day I love Paul it's still a great sport
yeah it's American sports you know so a
great sport yeah I think some people
watch the Super Bowl some mm-hmm would
say 44 million yeah but also mmm for
Boston 2 and 10 yeah that's way back
yeah maybe down a little bit cos parents
are worried about it but even the more
the more research we get with CT it's
like yeah we do for posterity stamps now
they have the XFL tried watch it I just
can't the XF oh I'm okay with a break
yet XFL is there uh you know I I'm gonna
see my the big boys I really enjoyed
watching the Super Ball on a massive
screen that was that clear you can just
see every little detail it's better than
being there
yeah book being there [ __ ] being there
is rehearsal yeah it's ass but [ __ ] I
think I might go to the Adesanya fight
the oral Meryl chill it's real
Romero's last chance at a championship
and I believe you're gonna see you al
Romero use all his wrestling and just
put it in go for broke that it's in an
eight I thought it was in April for some
reason I think it is April you're
sometime on March seventh a lot soon
yeah I gotta go
is it in Vegas yeah do you mobile arena
yep that's Vegas good card every time it
goes to a draw yeah I mean or if it's
close fight you all loses they just he
just loses for the most part I haven't
my autumn Adam winning that last but
Whitaker fight
that's old could we get they still got
Whitaker pence verse you could see the
same way me saying Whaley the the beast
oh yeah
you're doing this you wanna understand
so the main card yeah well I'm a gray
this guy's killing it right now yeah
Edmunds a monster which guy mr. Bastian
Shabazz Ian he's like the next big thing
in the middle way dude I don't know he's
a [ __ ] sniper yeah is it worse a
problem obviously for outdoor sniper
trains with Ronda's oh yeah Edmund oh
he's a sniper he's a [ __ ] beast
really yes
I'm 70 yeah you know I think 70 hmm he's
such a beast yeah the karts pretty good
you'd go to seed it's always better on
TV men yeah let's do some current events
yeah let's do it all right you know
Brian I talk a lot about physical
fitness non-stop Brian's obsessed with
dudes body's non-stop you want to talk
about it but what about your mental game
dude what about mental fitness I'm gonna
help you guys out calm the number one
app for sleep meditation has teamed up
with LeBron James to help train yo mind
LeBron and calm knows that your mind is
like any other muscle in your body and
calm can help you train your brain so
you sleep better you have less stress
and perform at your best mental Fitness
is so dang important if you need to get
your mind right go to calm calm slash
fighter you get 40% off the column
premium membership with calm you have
access to all sorts of stuff all right
sounds sleep stories meditations for a
limited time you guys can get it join
LeBron James and many others using calm
with 40% discount to an annual
membership at calm calm slash fighter
unlock content to help you focus each
stress sleep better get started at calm
CA LM calm slash fighter calm calm slash
runner this is the first one you guys
know they're very famous singer Sam
Smith yeah he posted this video some
random Asian kids singing inside looks
like a Best Buy or something like that
equivalent
thus by check out his horse
holy Sh right his friend don't give a
[ __ ] here he's in he's in a moment
it's
[Applause]
goddamn right a chill back damn
Jesus No
to cook her in the same outfit - yeah
[Applause]
Jesus Christ
oh what a badass
[Applause]
why is no money stopping all right then
even that's very end you don't really
hear much applause either I'd say yes
people roll yeah three million oh my god
I'm gonna guess he found out by now God
is he good
Christ it's good you would not expect
that I know you that was so cool
I don't like his friend wasn't that hype
I don't like the way his friends hold
his hands like either you got to be
flexible that's a different country and
that's amazing yeah and they don't give
a [ __ ] no two people exactly seen it
before dear Wow no sick all right do
when he finds out who it is that kid has
to have a freakin career after this a
singing career after this cuz he's so
weird looking in I love that although
what someone looks like you know yeah
yeah this is a viral picture of Trump
and his face yeah how crazy is that
he says it's fake he says it's fake news
that I see the Sun God so why are people
saying this Trump's a message more fake
news this was photoshopped obviously but
the wind was strong and the hair looks
good looks good hey Naveen
there you go Donald is by far a shock
but he's [ __ ] away I don't know
that's photos job they would they won't
let him leave them yeah when he was
talking about [ __ ] he's so but you never
know cuz he's so [ __ ] good at coming
back when he was talking about Mayor
Bloomberg he goes he goes I mean the guy
they this is so good he goes look the
guy short it's okay if you're short I
don't care but you don't get a box you
don't get to stand on a box you get a
box back in the box I think nobody ever
said like who they're like did he ever
ask for that no but that's how such a
girl he's doing guys ask him for a box I
make it work week well [ __ ] it Mike you
know he didn't say that he does I mean
if he's gonna stand on a box and I get
to stand up that's all I mean I just
don't understand why he needs a box if
you wanna be sure it's okay to be sure
he's making like recall it's like you're
such a killer he's mine it's just she's
such a killer now he makes it about his
height I mean you gotta love the guy
variety I find him so entertaining I'm
not saying you know I've been vocal
about how I don't like him as a but
Jesus Christ he's hard to be
it's good luck everybody I know good
luck
whatever luck a couple of animal ones
here this was very interesting a coyote
and a badger yeah they're actually if
you watch this video they look like
they're homies my homies yeah watch god
bad just have no homies I thought so
check him out he's calling him the
badger waitin badger comes along okay
and then they travel together now what I
think is that badger is being led to his
death I think that [ __ ] foxes have
his back yeah stupid enough to fall down
this dark holes he can rip his face
that's right I read that they team up
for hunting oh yeah yeah the badger gets
them into a hole learning the coyote
gets him after the badger finds him or
the other way around him yeah it was
cool yeah that's badass
partners in crime yeah I'll deal with
Brian I think that Fox groups the best
although there's as your badgers giving
it giving you the what for well are you
thinking the honey badger though your
common bang even Badgers will [ __ ] you
up man there goes the badger can dig
into the ground squirrels dens and then
once the prey surfaces the coyote can
chase it down they work together
that's it's not uncommon for badgers and
coyotes to team up wow that is really
cool yeah they're just partners in crime
huh that's really cool team up no
separate animals mm-hmm I don't know
that just partner up well here's this
isn't well you see this picture there's
a video of it actually us liking to a
bad boot carrying a mine it's like it's
blanking eat that yeah yeah past first
yeah
oh yeah he's definitely a killer thing
yeah does he kill it you kind of
grooming him this is grooming him oh
yeah it's called tenderize let's see it
looks just like blanking yeah so it's
kind of be nice to it a little bit and
then a Suzy puck but to marry ride trip
over beans with this that lines liking
it but you don't realize what they're
gonna do it's not baby cub yeah that's
that's the end of that video is not fun
hold up watch the incredible and
never-before-seen moment a male baboon
stole stole like up and started screwing
it what's alive and healthy this is
amazing sight and we've seen on safari
yeah
so they're not gonna let that line grow
to be a big old line and kill them so
what's gonna do is when you guys walk
away oh there you go hmm yeah I mean
maybe but you hope but says the Cubs
seem very exhausted I don't see a
chances poor cup survived yeah yeah
think doc the troop of baboons was large
and a lion would not be able to get the
young back nature's cruel most times and
survival young prepared cab is not easy
the lion cub would pose a threat to the
baboons when it gets older I have
witnessed baboons visually killing
leopard cubs and have heard baboons
killing lion cubs of course yeah it
doesn't look like it was that in here
what she's gonna do is so if they want
to keep rolling that tape it's gonna
take its head like this okay yeah go
probably yeah you ever see how chimps
eat other monkey's they pull them apart
like this
hey you wanna like oh you got some
strength on you that poor [ __ ] lion
dude yeah nature so so cute to him
nature's a [ __ ] I'm gonna groom you
then I bite you in the neck there you
have it and baboons got some teeth but
also we're the words of journalism let
me get some follow up here dude
but Boone's baboons have some teeth
there's some canine they got some Cana
and Samantha's yeah hey asses and
canines
I got a how much time yet brah I gotta
go
all right don't why sure just well let's
see what's a good one here you li knew
all the read though gonna kill me anyway
this is a sucky one but a nice man saw
his neighbor getting attacked by pit
bulls that were most likely his I think
tried to kill it
so it actually he did hit the pit bull
with the crossbow yeah but it went
through him and then it hit the guy
after he closed the door
yeah and killed the guy yeah that's
tough one yeah well video no that's not
the guy by the way is something else
that's tough for me it's a tough one
years ago [ __ ] dude he got pitbull what
the heroin right and weighted or the pit
bull right yeah then the poop was right
over him yeah sure no the guy slept so
the guy that was getting attacked after
the the guy saw the pit bull running
after him he closed the door he killed
the pit bull the arrow went through the
pit bull through the
door and then through him Oh as he was
quite you know yeah crossbows are yeah
powerful they go through steel geez
that's quick that's what so crossed by
the invest in the crossbow rendered
knighthood obsolete
overnight you know that see a member
Knights would wear all the armor and
then they invented the crossbow and now
that became your steel coffin I'm a
nighttime chivalrous cool
shite che dude sweet on it and you can't
move took two hours to put on cool and
you have the mesh underneath that's so
cool that close the front for me wow
that's what happened today yeah so there
you go West Palm Beach come see me
Friday Saturday Sunday random where you
gonna be
Ontario Ontario Thursday Friday Saturday
Valentine's Day get you some next week
Vancouver once your only Vogue theater
that thing's almost sold out jfl vogue
Theatre Vancouver February 21st then I
end the month in Tacoma Washington
27:29 get your Teague's that thief at
kake.com that's it dude you got to run
for us
alright this the fire kid route